the high concept for the black adam  series is there is no redemption  for black adam it is a very very  different look at this character  if this guy does exist if he is 5 000  years old if he does have this kingdom  in the middle of this turbulent region  what would that be like  he's pure villainy in the same way that  somebody like dracula is and uh what  we're trying to do is add dimension and  nuance he is now someone who is facing  his own mortality and is obsessed with  legacy every step that black adam takes  toward redemption causes fractions  within his with his own his own country  rafa sandoval arrives with a thunder  clap that is just amazing  now is the perfect time for this  approach for the black adam character  you